frío es un estudiante de 17 años sueña
con ir a la universidad y estudiar
psicología ella hace parte de los
llamados gamers o aquellos que huyeron
de sus países y llegaron indocumentados
a estados unidos siendo menores de edad
fría tiene fe en que el nuevo gobierno
le permita obtener un estatus permanente
para seguir sus estudios universitarios
aj
espero poder tener muchas más
oportunidades de las que he tenido y que
no tuve en los últimos cuatro años
espero que mis padres también tengan más
oportunidades prensa tienen a
presidentes as desde su primer día en el
poder
joe biden mandó al congreso su plan
migratorio con el fin de beneficiar a
millones de indocumentados para
legalizar su estatus sin embargo el
camino para lograrlo puede ser muy largo
en el senado los republicanos siendo
minoría podrían usar el llamado
filibusterismo para bloquear el proyecto
de ley se trata de una maniobra de
obstrucción utilizada desde 1840 en este
caso si los republicanos no están de
acuerdo sobre si someter el plan
migratorio de bailén a votación entonces
pueden tratar de debatir para que no se
vote los demócratas deben conseguir el
apoyo de al menos 10 republicanos en el
senado para que la iniciativa no
enfrente un proceso de filibusterismo es
por eso que muchos indocumentados son
escépticos con lo que pueda suceder si
el congreso tiene la voluntad de
resolver este problema y aprobar la ley
migratoria o aprobar algún tipo de
legislación para brindarles a los
dreamers un futuro ellos pueden hacerlo
pero no sé si tienen la voluntad
necesariamente
con el plan de bailén cerca de 13
millones de jóvenes en eeuu podrían
beneficiarse del programa de acción
diferida para los llegados en la
infancia para renovar su estadía en el
país hasta 2020 cerca de 700.000 jóvenes
estaban protegidos de la deportación